ep's crazy
i was extremely because i felt like
every time i was talking to anybody
uh it was like i've talked to people at
def jam like and they're bringing your
name up
like everybody's trying to sign this
fool this was before this was like
around the time beno dropped his project
but
everybody had already kind of known like
you're the guy that's next
up um you signed with red bull
which is very unconventional i know
warren brew was [ __ ] with red bull
and yeah um why why what
kind of give us the rundown on that
decision because it definitely caught me
by surprise
so i'm um i'm signed under my own
airplane which is eagle
we did a partnership with red bull so um
yeah basically eagle is my team that
right put together
and uh right now it's just like a
management because i'm the only artist
that they focus on
got you and uh well red bull yeah every
everybody be saying like why you doing
why you go with red bull i wanted to go
to unconventional route because this was
my first
time doing paperwork with anybody so i
wanted to be strategic and i didn't want
it to
be something where it's like a long
situation you know what i'm saying i
wanted to do something where i can
learn the ropes and things and it was
the perfect fit for me because they
understood uh
my position and my value as being a
producer as well
so i feel like yeah it was the perfect
situation it's a short-term
it's a short-term deal so are you
technically a free agent now
um i'm not going to say that because i
do want to i got some plans that i'm not
speaking on right now but so you've
already signed the
the big big deal
[Laughter]
i know i've heard some people trying to
get at you is it everybody
a lot of people have been tapping there
but i'm just trying to take my time with
it like
yeah like i feel like uh the the mistake
most people
make is like you're like
you're doing what you're supposed to be
doing if a major label
got involved tomorrow like it might
speed up like
some things but you're you're like
there's not a lot of major label can
bring to the table that you're not
already
yeah besides money and that's gonna come
that's a fact but
even uh like red bull they definitely
helped
crazy like with my situation like just
with the publications and everything
helping me put together
my rollout oh they was really on their
[ __ ] every idea we came up with
they was they was down to to produce it
or you know figure out ways they can be
a part of it
i mean that company is very they're they
do a lot of dope dope [ __ ] that's like
people obviously equate it to an energy
drink but
they do so much ill [ __ ] oh yeah they
fire [ __ ] with red bull
records absolutely [ __ ] with red bull
records
and only drink red bull because it gives
you wings
i mean do you get free red bull for life
i hope so
i mean i'm assuming you have cases no
yeah they definitely blessed me with the
cases
which is lovely but yeah i don't know if
i get it for life though there's like a
red bull airplane competition have you
seen that
they got so many sports it's so many oh
no but they have like a competition with
these [ __ ] airplanes doing crazy ass
[ __ ] bro it's like
like well like tricks bro yeah it's like
from like the wild yeah i've seen that
[ __ ] red bull man
they were raging over there yeah
everything extreme they're part of it